how do you write a great scene ooh I
think you should look at your scenes
like you look at the whole screenplay
and figure out the cause and effect of
what does this seem cause to happen and
how is it how is it the effect of what
happened before it understanding that in
every scene there is a goal just like
there is in the entire screenplay the
only reason we're seeing this scene is
because it's getting you closer to or
further away from your goal and so if
you look at it like there's a goal that
has to be reached so that you can get to
the next thing that gets to the next
thing that gets to the next thing then
you end up not having scenes that are
back to just regular activity instead of
intentional action or even considering
from an actor's point of view when
they're gonna play out that scene one of
them is winning right somebody's gonna
win in this thing in this scene you know
it's kind of like it's a fact it's a
fight it's a ding ding ding in this
corner and in this corner these
characters are gonna come and whatever
it is that they're saying to each other
someone's gonna win emotionally
someone's gonna lose someone might
physically win someone might lose but
what that means is now that emotional
journey that I was on has been changed
again it's the cause and effect so there
might be a physical cause and effect
there might be an emotional cause and
effect or it might be both but
definitely looking at the little looking
at the scenes like they're little movies
right like what is it setting up for me
what's the goal of this scene and then
how does it resolve to get me to the
next thing so if we were to take the
hypothetical female character who was
entering a singing contest now she's
found out that her mother needs this
deposit to start treatment so that great
scene is going to be maybe her getting
that news and then she knows that that
contest is coming up and all the things
that she's got to do to prior I don't
know just because the stakes are risen
it's not just like oh yeah I need it for
my dorm yeah where I want to buy an ice
bag or something yeah so now her action
because of that scene because of that
new information her intentional action
is going to change so maybe before then
she wasn't practicing very much because
she's got a natural voice you know so
she wasn't practicing very much she
wasn't finding any new songs she's like
oh yeah I'll just I'll go up there I was
you know whatever cuz every time I sing
this song it's great but now this thing
has been a humbling moment for her right
so now we're gonna see her going to her
lessons we're gonna see her trying to
find the best song like she's going to
be putting a different kind of action
into it because now the stakes are risen
now there's something something more at
stake right so now she's gonna put a
different kind of action into it so that
thing is gonna cause her to change
exactly mm-hmm
you